la ansiedad está en el aire
para entregar la lista 3 a 4 la presión
ejercida por la inmensa caravana de
emigrantes comienza a dar frutos
los agentes de aduana de huixtla al sur
de méxico están colapsados a duras penas
y en contra de lo políticamente
establecido refrendan miles de
pasaportes el de juan manuel herrera ex
militar venezolano aún no aparece
siendo el día 9 de junio del 2022 a las
una y media de la tarde como podemos
observar la gran multitud de inmigrantes
de diferentes nacionalidades
-juan manuel narra lo que comenzó tres
días atrás en la frontera sur de méxico
cerca de 10.000 migrantes con rumbo a
eeuu
partieron en caravana el mismo día que
se inauguró la cumbre de las américas de
los ángeles california el éxito
mediático estaba asegurado
habiendo recorrido 50 kilómetros de
tapachula huixtla juan manuel explica la
esencia de la caravana una marcha que
bueno pidiendo de manera humilde al
gobierno mexicano que nos impregna la
misión humanitaria para poder seguir
nuestro camino sabiendo de que esté el
derecho a inmigrar es un derecho
internacional
un derecho que en tapachula la ciudad
fronteriza de donde partió la caravana
se ahoga en un engorroso proceso
burocrático que tarda meses -juan manuel
herrera
pero corren los rumores que por el
camino hacia eeuu las autoridades les
rompen a los migrantes de este documento
así que juan manuel fraga un plan para
evitar que le sucediera los documentos
telefónicamente una vez llegó a dallas
texas te voy a ser sincero conocí una
persona que tiene un transporte de
obreros en huila y me disfrazaron
disfrazaron como si fuera un obrero me
pusieron un chaleco como si fuera una
película de hollywood entonces así fue
que logré pasar
la suerte de juan manuel no fue la misma
para los miles de emigrantes que
avanzaron en la parte trasera de la
caravana y que por ende llegaron tarde a
huixtla
marta esmeralda salvadoreña intenta no
desesperarse y confía que al día
siguiente obtendrá su permiso migratorio
en nuestro país el motivo de los
problemas de la familia con 17 años esta
madre soltera sabe que su juventud le
fue robada no es por capricho que se
aferra al sueño americano pues sabes que
fueron maltrato de las personas que lo
miraban a uno pues yo a veces me quería
matar yo me quería perder de todas
maneras
entonces este cuando el niño nació pues
yo me puse no se sentía qué alegría en
mi corazón
[Música]
si alguien es sensible ante el drama que
atraviesan los migrantes es luís rey
garcía villagrán el líder de la caravana
son son 20 pollos esté por ahí otra
gente nos está donando otros 20 pollos
tortillas este pan algunas mil o dos mil
peces piezas de pan hasta donde podamos
pero lo más importante para ellos es su
documento tras más de 12 años en prisión
por un crimen que no cometió y del que
fue absuelto
luís rey se convirtió en activista por
los derechos de los migrantes
ahorita voy a la cancha y cómo se llama
mapastepec
en mapastepec a luís rey lo espera un
grupo de más de mil migrantes los pollos
y los panes son insuficientes y se
reparten entre un desespero colectivo si
no hay orden no vamos a poder hacer las
cosas bien ya le pasan a otro pollo vaya
ya es el quinto día desde que partió la
caravana pese a notarse el pesimismo
luís rey les infunde la ilusión de que
obtendrán el visado aquí no van a
descansar
sábado y domingo migración migración va
a tragar trabajar para entregarles el
ansiado documento que los exime de ser
capturados y remitidos al centro de
detención migratoria de tapachula
conocido como siglo 21
públicamente una denuncia
directora de la estación migratoria
vamos a denunciarla
la repubblica por tortura física y
tortura mental en contra de compañía
en este campamento muchos migrantes
pasaron por aquel centro de detención
fronterizo al que califican de cárcel lo
que sería es un infierno por el sistema
de que tengan yo de la comida del hogar
yo en la comida cosa que que no entiendo
para qué
oscar rolando y su esposa emigraron de
honduras por la situación económica
al entrar ilegalmente a méxico fueron
llevados a la estación siglo 21 de
tapachula en esta en esta tarde estuve
19 días aislado necesitamos más respeto
en méxico porque no somos delincuentes
no somos ni delincuentes ni mareros ni
terroristas ni cosa que se parezca bien
y merecemos respeto
esa misma noche en mapastepec varios
autobuses del instituto nacional de
migración mexicano arribaron con la
promesa de transportar a los migrantes a
la aduana de huixtla para finiquitar el
trámite migratorio
oscar rolando creyó en lo prometido sin
sospechar que en lugar de obtener su
permiso migratorio fuera devuelto a
tapachula
100 kilómetros de sand a 2 como
consecuencia de que la caravana había
sido fragmentada el foco mediático se
había apagado y méxico volvía a tomar el
control de su política antiinmigrantes